we begin with some breaking news just
coming in in the last hour or so
buckingham palace says britain's queen
elizabeth is under medical supervision
after her doctors reported quote concern
for her health the statement says the
queen is in a comfortable state although
buckingham palace rarely comments on her
health the exact concerns have not been
disclosed prince charles who's the heir
to the throne is reported to be with the
queen and other members of the royal
family are traveling to her estate in
scotland
well let's cross over straight to london
now where dw's bigger mouse is standing
by bigger what more can you tell us
it's really a developing situation
rebecca we have this official statement
that the queen is not well and as you
said that is quite unusual i have not
had the palace commenting much on the
queen's health and never with any
anything so serious so we know that the
queen has not been in great health of
late many of her engagements that she
was always during her whole lifetime
so eager to attend and person and that
she so dutifully attended many of those
have lately been
virtual so she wasn't really able to go
places very much and liz trust the prime
minister was meeting the queen only two
days ago and usually that would happen
in buckingham palace but uh the list
trusts and also the outgoing prime
minister boris johnson they had to
travel up to scotland to meet the queen
because she had as it was then said
mobility issues so we don't really know
what the problem is and in what way her
situation has deteriorated but something
must have happened because otherwise the
children and grandchildren now it's been
reported that also harry and megan are
on their way to scotland otherwise
all this family wouldn't travel up to
see the queen yes certainly in that
statement you know phrases such as
medical supervision cause for concern it
it certainly does sound very serious
right and different to what they whether
that they don't normally comment on her
health as you say
that's right when she contracted kovi
there was already
um a bit of a shock going through the
country and people were waiting their
breath and hoping that she would recover
that was just this one statement that
she
had had covered but that she was doing
fairly well and then she has recovered
from that from all we know but not very
many public um appearances by her she
was surprisingly opening up the
elizabeth line that's a big new project
in london that was obviously named after
her so that was delighting many british
people that she was there but nobody had
been expecting that that happened this
summer so
very recently she has had um yeah very
low-key engagements and and mostly
virtual
now as you mentioned we know that the
queen's health hasn't been great of late
but you as you also mentioned we saw
photos of her just on tuesday accepting
the resignation of outgoing prime
minister boris johnson as well as
appointing the new prime minister liz
truss so she still has been managing to
carry out some official duties in the
last few days
yes very much so and these pictures that
um have emerged from these meetings show
her smiling and welcoming liz strauss as
the new prime minister and also she was
able to meet boris johnson so we we know
that above anything she's known for her
sense of duty and she would have most
likely um like to go to buckingham
palace and meet those outgoing and
incoming prime ministers there but it
wasn't possible but it really speaks for
um this sense that she has to stick it
through that she even with her ongoing
issues she was um
seen on a walking stick that she managed
to
to meet these two prime ministers and
that she is really determined to
she was really determined to continue
working as much as she could all right
bigger thank you very much dw's bigot
mouse in london
with me in the studio is dw reporter
alex forrest whiting alex we just heard
from biget there but just
for people just joining us and just so
that we have everything together
summarize for us what we know so far
well we know that the queen who has been
queen for 70 years she um rose to the
throne in 1952
we know that she is unwell so unwell
that
bucky and palace has issued a statement
about that
saying that her doctors are concerned
for her health at the moment but we
don't have any more detail about the
situation of her health
what we do know is that members of her
family some are already
at balmoral that's in the north of
scotland where the queen currently is
some are with her for example prince
charles and his wife camilla and others
are traveling there so for example
prince edward prince andrew two of her
sons are traveling there and also prince
william and we also hear that uh prince
harry and his wife megan are also
traveling to balmoral so that in itself
says that this is a very serious
situation um by the fact that members of
the family are gathering in the north of
scotland to be by her bedside and also
the buckingham palace has made this
statement saying that doctors have said
they are very concerned about her health
we do also know of course that the queen
has had serious mobility problems in the
past couple of years at least that has
been said um that means that we have not
seen her as much in public as we have
done in the past but she has still very
much tried to carry out her public
duties which is what big at mass was
saying there you know that sense of duty
yeah which i think has been so key
um to queen elizabeth's rule over these
70 years that she has always tried to
carry out her sense of beauty and
nothing can stop her from doing that not
even when her own husband prince philip
died last year she carried on absolutely
and we saw on tuesday of course you know
she can't have been feeling all that
well either and yet she did you know
want to as big it said you know it was
very important to her that she carry out
the duties of accepting the resignation
of boris johnson and then uh appointing
liz truss uh talk us through some of the
immediate reactions that this news is
triggering well we already know that um
liz trust who is the new prime minister
has um said that she is very worried um
and we know that our other politicians
have
said the same in the uk we know that the
archbishop of canterbury um who is um
he's not the head of the church of
england because that's actually the
queen um but he has also said that he is
praying that the whole church of england
is praying for the queen and there are
also messages coming in from across the
world so i think people are very very
worried i mean you have to understand
that the queen is not just the queen of
the united kingdom she's also
yeah
the headed state of 14 other countries
including australia including canada
and 12 others so this is a very very um
important moment for the world and for
many countries as well and as i said you
know she has been queen for 70 years she
celebrated her platinum jubilee earlier
this year um it is a milestone she's 96
years old
she has been taking a step back over the
past year or two quite understandable
quite understandably her own son prince
charles for example um was at the state
opening of parliament this year that the
picture we have in the war behind us
that's the queen at the state opening of
parliament um in london so in the house
of lords when she wasn't there this year
prince charles had to do it so he has
already been stepping up to take on some
of the roles that she would have done in
previous times as has her grandson
prince william so um you know everybody
has been trying to do their bit back her
up as much as possible but as we keep
saying the queen has always tried to do
has uh carry out her sense of duty
carry on particularly this week it's
been a massive week
in in british politics saying goodbye to
boris johnson who i think was her 15th
prime minister and welcoming i think her
16th prime minister liz truss but
yesterday she was supposed to have a
meeting with very senior ministers the
so-called privy council that was
cancelled so i think that was an
immediate warning of
perhaps the queen is not particularly
well at the moment because again that's
not something that she likes to do and
then this announcement today from
buckingham palace that doctors are
concerned for her health and also the
fact that she was er she's in balmoral
and not in buckingham palace perhaps
that says something as well because she
would of course always be in buckingham
palace to welcome a new prime minister
um the last 15 or so prime ministers but
she was unable um it appears to get back
to london so she stayed in the north of
scotland and that is her summer
residence but it is unprecedented that
she would be up there so again that was
another indication on such a big
political week in the united kingdom
that the queen was up in the north of
scotland and not down in london um so
that she could welcome in the new prime
minister liz truss
all right alex we'll of course be
following this story throughout the
evening and the coming days thanks very
much for that update alex forrest
whiting
you